a particle moves according to the
equation and then they give you this
equation what a plain boring particle
but so he doesn't okay where X is the
displacement in meters so this is me
from the origin R at time T seconds
after time zero meters per second is
firing away the most common unit
combination you will see okay
however you would always see that
combination you'll get different kinds
of lengths and time units and you have
to be careful wherever conversion is
involved
okay and this is a simple one so I'm not
sure if I need to draw it up whatever
copy complete this table which shows the
value displacement at certain times so
just for the sake of it okay what does
it matter they give us zero one two
three we can do this in our heads we
time zero time 1 1 minus 4 that's
negative 3 time to now and what should
you get used to say when you see zero
saying at the origin that's what it
means okay
resist thinking that just as numbers you
always want to be interpreting always
always build it into what you're doing
at time - we are at the origin at time 3
we are ok no they haven't said anything
about up down left right all those kinds
of things all we know is that we're on
one side of the origin and then we're on
the other side whichever that is whether
it's up down the fryer
that's fine fix it I don't know how but
anyway I've just go across I'll cut it
out later puppy
hence find the average velocity now
here's where language very simple
average velocity and then they give you
a series of time intervals now let me
emphasize that an average right it
requires an interval it requires a start
and an end right and then you think
about how far you've gone in that time
and how long has pushed
okay now the interval the first give you
is during the first second okay during
the first second now remember this is
not a point in time you can't have an
average at a point in time yet that
average over an interval right so the
question is where is the beginning and
end
where are the beginning and end of this
interval it's from zero to one isn't it
the reason why I'm laboring this point
is because people see first second and
they go t equals one because it's the
foot you know but that's not what it
means at all and it can't because T
equals one is a point and an average
requires an interval okay
so that's why I want to know at T equals
zero and T equals one what's going on
okay
so I would write
okay how do you work out something like
this okay you want to work out total
displacement over displacement over time
okay
now be careful with this right it went
from negative 4 to negative 3 hmm
so what direction was it moving in
because we don't know up down that's
right all we can say is it was moving in
the positive direction okay so therefore
what I'm gonna have here is positive
even though these values are negative
the way I'm going where I'm being
displaced is that way so it's positive
what's the actual value from negative 4
to negative 3 which is what that's
that's where I'm going now sir how long
it took me one second
okay so this would be one in that space
of time okay average velocity now you
can know because for instance suppose if
suppose we got it wrong and we said no
no look these are negatives so I must be
negative and I said negative 1 over we
know time is 1 right and then you look
at this it says negative 1 meters per
second now does that match what happens
here is it moving in the negative
direction and the answer is no it's
maybe the other way toward the origin
which is positive okay
so that's how you've got to be careful
with signs and make sure you check
against your answers again saying what
you expect
part 2 during the first 3 seconds
so again people get thrown they see why
they see three so they go t equals one
and T equals three
sorry oh that's okay let's skip to let's
get it let's get it okay so people get
confused by the numbers right which are
the first three seconds it's from here
to here that's the first one then to
here there's the second one as well then
all the way to the last value that
interval is the first three seconds
three seconds of collapse so when you're
working yeah average velocity and by the
way I totally recommend that you
actually write the word average V on its
own it almost always just indicates
instantaneous okay that's kind of my
default because the averages they kind
of sort of fade away and we think we can
do calculus we don't need to take
approximations over time we can just
know the exact speed exact velocity so
therefore write average it's a good idea
how far has it moved it's gone from
negative 4 to 5 right so half fires have
been displaced it's been displaced nine
units in the positive direction right so
I've got plus nine over there you'll see
I'll do this a lot by the way when
whenever we're talking about things
where I'm particularly where I'm not
sure about is up down that's right I'll
actually put a plus so that I know I
mean we never put pluses right please
make sure I know what direction we're
going in how many seconds reason okay
this is not that hard is it but it's
easy to get it wrong now let me give you
a really main question okay this is
seriously what people would trip about
what if I say during the second second
what is that where is that hmm so we've
already got the first second here which
was from zero to one so the next one
along is not here but here right so then
you need to know time equals one and
equals two and that's where you're gonna
calculate distance which I guess would
be from here yeah it's three isn't it
you mean it's per second room okay
so you're getting the idea does this
make sense
interesting by the way I'll let you have
a think about why is it that because if
I do the young if I do the numbers
average velocity it is going to be three
over one second which is three why are
these the same is that a coincidence